to boldly go where no man has been
before or how about revisit exactly
where you started the Starship
Enterprise will be returning to our TV
and a shooting date has been confirmed
I'm Simon and this is your Trekkie news
update while Star Trek has become a
massive box office draw in the past few
years it has been over a decade since
the long-running sci-fi franchise was
seen on TV this will change next year
when a new star trek show premieres and
the shooting location and start date has
now been confirmed as announced by CBS
on Twitter the new show will begin
production this fall in Canada while the
title cost and broadcast day are yet to
be announced it was revealed in February
the former Hannibal showrunner Bryan
Fuller will oversee the show alongside
Alex Kurtzman who co-wrote the last two
movie adventures while the first episode
will be broadcast on the CBS network
channel all subsequent episodes will
initially screen on the company's all
access digital subscription service
making it the first show to launch on a
broadcast network by air primarily on a
VOD service the last series with star
trek enterprise which ran for four
seasons between 2001 and 2005 if you
can't wait for the new Star Trek TV
series you can look forward to the next
motion picture star trek beyond which
opens on july twenty second whether you
like Star Trek or you're actually more
of a Star Wars fan it definitely looks
like space is the final frontier all the
producers want to explore let me know
what you think in the comments or come
find me on Twitter i'm at the jagan all
thanks for watching a for all your
entertainment news keep it gamespot